I slightly change the title but it seems
to be the thing to do here so yeah but
the content is going to be left
n-channel don't don't worry so first of
all I would like to thank the organizer
for for being here and since they
explained to us on Saturday that it was
very good to present fail result that's
basically what I am going to do today
okay so I'm going to speak about ISO -
any best crypto and an adaptation we try
to do with with one of my postdoc called
Ananda and why is this is going to run
into problem but it was very interesting
because it's it really seems to go very
very very nicely so first thing okay we
had lots of talks about ISO Geneva's
crypto this morning but maybe some of
you were not to wake or not a or
whatever so I'm going to make a short
recap about that stuff maybe in slightly
different way so when we speak about ISO
Geneva's crypto we speak about elliptic
curve but not in the usual way
usually in crypto when we are looking at
elliptic curve we have the curves you
look at the point Z from a group
whatever but but when you look at when
you do a search any base crypto you try
to forget about this and just say okay
so curves are just going to be points
and they are going to be a relation
between the curve which is the existence
of maps between them and these maps are
called ISO Jennie's and we we don't care
about the point on the curve in some way
okay we might care a little bit to
construct the ISO journey but this is
kind of secondary what is really
important as we pass in the ISO journey
graph okay so well what I so journey is
we saw this morning but there are two
views of what isoh journeys are
depending on how you view your
elliptical so if you like to work about
the complex numbers this is an
elliptical in it's also two-dimensional
lattice and you you quotient are two by
two two dimensional realities and this
is the interior of this parallelogram is
the elliptical what
nice Oh genie if you just cut your
parallelogram in two or three or
whatever and then and then you just
reduce modulo circuit part and this is
the iso genius curve this is much easier
to understand than the nor the rest but
it's it's basically the same thing okay
so this is an iso journey between
between elliptic curve and i am cheating
a little bit here because what counts is
not only the shape of the ladies so you
can choose an arbitrary basis of the
deities as usual but you can also scale
your ladies by an arbitrary constant and
it's considered to be the same curve
okay so this is a more simple view of
isogen is between curves and the other
of you is you have one curve and you
have a map that sends points with the
other Kevin and there is a channel and
everything and and you can compute as we
saw see small okay so so this is that
this is really having two curves on
rotating them by a map and of course so
there is one thing which is extremely
nice yeah is when you have a nice option
is there is all always narrow backward
called the dual iso journey and when you
look at the fully geometric view it's
really easy to see the dual lysogeny
what you do after cutting in alfe like
this you cut in alf in the other
direction and now as you see that after
doing it twice you have just divided
your full your full letís by two so you
can just grow it up because it's up to a
multiplicative constant so if you are
really going back to the same okay so
once you have done that if you do you I
so Jenny is you have this I so Jenny
graph where each star is curved and each
link between the between the star is an
eye surgeon so yeah I just shows I so
Jenny all of the same degree and
forgetting about volcano stuff and
whatever I'm just getting a big cycle
where I go from one curve to the others
and that's nice but the problem is if
you try to do any kind of crypto like
this it's going to be a really boring I
mean you start from here you can do in
one direction or the other but you are
not going to go very far and it's not
very interesting so if you want to do
something more interesting
you want more you want more on your
graph so we start from this graph and we
try to add stuff to it so to add stuff
to it we do put the I so Jen you have a
different degree so this gives more Khan
connects it in the graph we can go
faster and then we add even more and
even more if you want and at some point
the graph become really strongly
connected and you can jump from any
curve to any other following a kind of a
short pass okay and once you have this
we saw the ISO genichi exchange this
morning so what you do is you start from
an initial curve and then Alice chooses
some eyes OG&E starting from the curve
and move to a new curve which is
elliptic curve Alice and Bob move to a
curve of Bob and if they do this
incorrectly which might be a little bit
complicated for a side the edge but we
know how to do it what what Bob does he
takes the curve that Alice gave him and
he moves to the common curve and Alice
does the same and we have this nice
commutative diagram and we end up with
the same secret okay so far so good and
okay so your souls at this mode so now
what I want to do is I want to take this
and to replace the curves by something
else and so something else is something
called drinfeld modules while of wrong
too because these are kind of analogues
of elliptic curves so I'm not going to
be able to give full definition about
all these objects I'm just going to try
to give feeling about about this thing
on shows that they are really similar to
elliptic curves there are plenty of
similarities all over the place whatever
you know about elliptic curve you are
going to be able to find it about during
that module basically except one thing
which is really hard to find on drinfeld
module it's the notion of points so it's
kind of you have elliptic curve but you
don't have points okay so it's kind of
boring if you want to do classical
crypto because well we don't have point
to operator
well the thing is for I saw Jenny best
crypto we don't care we just said we
didn't care about the point
so it
very natural candidate to try to
transport these eyes only I saw Jenny
bears crypto sings okay so now let's try
to describe the setting
what drink fill modules are and and out
these things work so okay if you have
any question don't hesitate to ask me
because this is the first time I give
that tall so I don't know exactly how to
interact with the audience and this so
we will see okay so in the setting what
we start on which is really basic we
start from a finite field FQ we're cool
let's say it's prime to simplify things
it doesn't really matter and we consider
the ring of polynomial left Q of X and
now we assume that we have some map
gamma that that is a ring of a morphism
that sends this polynomial into some
subfield so one easy way to do that is
you just take an extension a finite
field extension of FQ and you just map X
to a generator of of F F Q to the N and
this is a very natural map so we could
even forget about gamma just assumes
that FQ is embedded into the into the
finite field but I prefer to keep it
around okay so now on this field err we
are going to have a Frobenius map we can
take an element raise it to the power Q
we know it's linear and we know that
it's nice on the morphism here of the
and what we are going to do is we are
going to consider an object which you
are not really used to write down in in
crypto but which is kind of useful
it's the ring of of skewed polynomials
which are going to be polynomials both
in X or maybe in in in in Omega if we
send X to Omega or generator of FQ to Zn
and in so which is which is the
Frobenius map and what is really
important is that when you write these
things down they are not going to be
committed so just just let's let's do a
simple multiplication of polynomial to
show why these things are not
commutative
okay so I don't know let's take the
polynomial tow plus Omega where Omega is
my generator okay and let's just square
this polynomial it was regular
polynomial what would you get you would
get 2 square plus 2 Omega 2 plus Omega
square but here because of the Frog of
the non whoops what happened my slide
vanished okay so probably something with
my computer I'm going to look at it
after so now if I'm squaring this what
is going to happen what is going to
happen is I get 2 square for sure but
then I get 2 Omega plus Omega tau plus
Omega square and now this is 4 bits of
Frobenius map ok so when when I want to
put Omega from the right to the left I'm
going to replace this by Omega to the Q
time tau this is why my my ring is my
polynomials are non commutative so just
remember this whenever you have a
constant that goes through tau it is
raised to the power cube and if it goes
through tau many times it is raised to
the power Q many times of course if you
just take your constant to be in the
finite field it's not going to be
problematic I don't know okay my
computer was sleeping so so if it so if
you have a constant which is in F Q
going through tau is not going to be a
problem but if you have a bigger
constant then it's going to something
different is going to other a constant
in a bigger field than something is good
ok so this is my setting so in that
setting
what is the drinfeld module so a
dreadful module is a new way to embed
this FQ to the X into into a ring of
twisted polynomial so so the drain file
module file is going to be given by the
image of X because if you know how to
embed X you know how to embed everything
the constant of a skewed you have no
choice you need to map them to themself
and Xu you can choose the image so what
we do is we first choose okay we we use
gamma gamma of X to start with which was
a canonical image we had before and we
are doing we are going to add a few
extra coefficient and the extra
coefficient are going to be a multiple
of tau on the multiple of tau Square and
the two air comes from the fact that I'm
considering drinfeld module of wrong too
so if it was going only to one it would
be called the calots module and if it
was going to three four five it would be
a drink'll module of rank three four
five okay and so I'm continuing max
setting so I am assuming that I'm going
to choose for my field K just the field
F of Q to the N defined by some by some
expression of this form so some so F Q
of X divided by some irreducible
polynomial of degree n okay and now what
is going to happen is when you come if
you consider the image by froggy news
it's really interest sorry by Phi it's
very interesting to look at the image of
the polynomial f of X itself and when
you construct the image of the
polynomial f of X something interesting
happens so clearly it's going to be a
polynomial in tau of degree 2 times n
because you have a polynomial of degree
2 and you have X to the N and so when
you compute the embedding you are going
to have these things raised to the power
and so you you are going to have
something of the grid of the width when
in tau but when you look at it the image
it's really interesting the constant
part is is just the image of f of X so
this is this is nice
but the rest of it is going to be a
small will people of total yet tau to
the N and a small on this tau to the 12
so this means that if you consider
tau to the N which is a very basic under
morphism it is just the Frobenius map
associated as
to F of Q to Z n it is going to satisfy
this characteristic polynomial and if
you are familiar with elliptic curve you
know that the Frobenius on the morphism
satisfy characteristic polynomial which
is of the form x square okay now to the
N squared fine
plus something which is called the tress
well - the tress time X plus P where P
is is the prime modulo which the curve
is defined when you look at the curve P
and here it is just replaced by the
polynomial so there is really this
analogy between the two this thing is
called as usual the trace of the trace
of the of the brainfail module okay and
we learn this morning about the fact
that using super single elliptic curve
is really nice to build isogen email
system well it's the same for rainfall
module using three pair singular thing
is really nice on what does super
singular mean in this context it means
that this T here is just going to be
zero
so it means that we have a very simple
image when we take the image of of F by
the by the drinfeld module we just
basically get the power of tau okay
yeah III told you so
it's because I am considering drinfeld
module of rank 2 which are the closest
analog of elliptical but but you could
try to consider higher rank differential
modules but the same kind of things that
I'm going to tell about wrong 2 would
also apply so it's you know you choose
all this thing at the same time so if
you choose a drinfeld module of rank L
it's going to act on every field
extension of FQ anyway so here I'm just
choosing to restrict what I am looking
at but I'm just looking at the action on
on this finite field but you could look
at the reaction on the algebraic closure
of the of FQ in fact it's like for an
elliptic curve usually we look when we
do crypto we look at point in a finite
field but the elliptic curve content
points in every extension and formally
you can tell about point in the
algebraic closure of all the things so
it's the same thing
you you you in fact you should be
looking at all the extension at the same
time but it's a little bit too much to
to write on the slides okay so what I'm
missing now I told you roughly what to
drinfeld module is what I'm missing now
is the notion of isogen so how do I go
from 1 - module to another and what is
an eye surgeon and an eye surgeon II its
kind of of simple it's going to be an
arbitrary well arbitrary need to satisfy
some property but it's going to be an
element of of the skewed polynomial ring
and it's going to be called an eye so
journey from fight oops I if it
satisfied this equation so if Utah is
such that yota composed with Phi is
equal to Phi composed with yota
then it's neither journey from fight
oops I okay this might seem a little bit
odd
official for salmon but I'm going to
show you examples on so very nice thing
is ok this this always works on constant
because basically no things happen so
you only need need to check that this is
true for the image of X so it's a very
it's kind of a very easy thing to check
so in order to do that I'm going to give
a concrete example because it's it's
probably going to be much easier to work
on this concrete example so the concrete
at the example first I am going to
choose the field F of P to the P for
soompi so give me P a small one let's
say what 101 or whatever you want and
I'm going to take this extension so this
extension why do I do I do that because
for this extension there is a very nice
polynomial that describe it it's looking
at the extension in art in Trier form
where you just use this irreducible
polynomial X to the P minus X plus 1 ok
I use plus 1 for technical reason rather
than minus 1 but it doesn't change
anything
ok and then I'm going to write this as
as FP of Omega so Omega is in that field
I'm going to choose a specific module
specific variant modules which which is
known to be super singular it's kind of
the same point the same thing as a
starting curve when we do a super single
elliptical so when we do super single
elliptical what we do is we choose Y
square equal X cubed plus X with P
congruent to 3 mod 4 ok here we choose
which was this thing with an odd degree
extension odd is the same thing as
congruent to 3 mod 4 essentially and on
this specific form is the same thing as
a really specific this is a super single
module so we are going to have this
equation where epsilon is some constant
which in fact is equal to 2 minus 1 so
in fact what happens is that if I
compute the image by this train fell
module of this polynomial I just get toe
to the 2 N and that's well well any
speed here so I just get taught with the
2 P and that's it and it's really kind
of easy to compute these things you just
have to work with these these
polynomials but it works and people who
have been familiar with things I did in
the past might be might recognize this X
to the P minus X it's something very
useful to do trickeries with in small
characteristics so I'm going to use it
again and what is going to happen is
that this X to the P minus X you all
know that this is the product you all
know that this X to the P minus X oops
it's just the product for every alpha in
FP of X minus alpha ok so it means that
if I take the product of all the images
buys by so drinfeld module of X minus
alpha I'm just going to get to to the
top to P sorry minus 1 minus 1 because
because this thing is just F minus 1
good now if you view this this thing tau
to the to P minus 1 so I told you this
is an under my office of something so
what I'm going to be interested in is
the CalNet of this thing so what does
what does it mean if I if I tell you
that this apply to Y is equal to 0 which
is the
and of saying that why is in the key
analysis this is going to tell me that
why to the P to the 2p minus y is equal
to 0 do you all see so it's just you
know computing the Frobenius one is
raising to the power tau so Computing's
of revenues to p times is raising to the
power P to the to P and you know that
the roots of this equation or the
element of the finite field F to the to
P which is a quadratic extension of
remember this morning we saw that for
for CPA's singular elliptic curve you
had to look in a quadratic extension for
all the gene variants so it's kind of
the same everything happens in a
quadratic extension if you want also all
the interesting things okay so we know
that this endomorphism which is the
image of the of the product of all
linear polynomial is just vanishing
everywhere on F to the to P so kind of
the kernel of this thing is all the
finite field so this is this is this is
nice this is going to be a nicer journey
with this as a kernel but it's very very
big so journey this kind of you take on
elliptic curve you multiply by the
number of points okay it's an iso
journey but really an interesting
because it sends all the best point you
are looking at to 0 which is basically
what is happening there okay so what is
going to be interesting if I want to do
I so Jenny pass and everything is to
make load low degree I so Jenny so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to build
low degree I so Jenny just from one
linear polynomial not fall from from all
of them at the same time just take one
okay so I just take one the image by by
Phi is just this is just this on the
morphism and if I want an element in the
kernel is just a solution of this
equation okay and when you look at the
solution of this equation it's kind of
clear that it is going to be an SP
vector space of dimension 2 so I'm just
drawing it yeah and exactly like in the
case of elliptic curve you just choose a
line that goes through 0 in this vector
space and you decide that ok I'm going
to look for the eyes oh Jenny we must
K&L is just this line and like we saw
this morning with ch ch sorry
commutative si DHC side there is a
specific line which is just best field
which is which is sorry which correspond
to the +1 eigen value of Frobenius
basically and there is a minus 1 eigen
value and if you do this for it for each
line you find you find the specific
polynomials that gives all the sorry all
the point on the line which loves which
will have this shape and I if I convert
back into the tower form I get a nice
OG&E which is a linear polynomial of
degree 1 where this constant is in the
finite fee the square of the finite
field paste P to the P as usual you can
just so as this morning we can look at
value of theta in the best field or in
the full field if we just look in the
best field we get the commutative stuff
if we look in the full field we will get
the non commutative stuff so there are
tons of similarity all the way I'm
trying to show them but it's kind of a
little bit difficult but yeah so if you
look at this I so journey to a minus
theta there is going to be a dual izo
journey which has this form on what is
going to happen is that if you compose
the two you just get Phi okay plus the
constant we chose if we composite wins
the other order
because of the non commutativity we are
going to get a different arrangement
module can the nice thing is when you
look at the composition utah at toyota
time utah at you remove the part
associated with a constant on one side
you find phi compose with utah add on
the on the other side you find your tad
compose with fat with try so we found a
nice oh jenny doing that okay it's a low
degree I so jenny of degree one and we
have tons of such OG&E one for each
constant in the finite field I can't
this is good because remember when we
did the elliptic curve this morning we
had either two on three shared between
Alice and Bob all we needed plenty of
small prime here we have plenty of small
of low degree sings kind of for free
okay so we can compute the ISO CI sajan
in both direction I'm not going to to
look to look at that too much because
there is little time left on you can do
it explicitly it's a very small example
P equals three but you get these three
pair singular infant modules together
with I so Jenny so this one correspond
to alpha equals zero if I add alpha
equal one and alpha equal equal to you
recognize your graph where you have
things everywhere and it's the same kind
of expander graph as before as in the
elliptical case so if we want to adapt
SIDS or suicide well basically we do as
before we have what what happens is that
for every choice of alpha we have P plus
1 I so genus of degree of degree 1 which
correspond to each of the direction okay
if you want to do the commutative
version you just choose the value
corresponding to theta in the field F of
people's of P on the Duval's so you can
do go one direction or the other but you
need plenty of primes well plenty of low
degree polynomials to make to make the
graph become an expander but what is
really nice is that everything
commute so you can you don't have to
worry about having to to give him a G's
or anything okay but you get two smaller
drives and in the other case so in that
case kind light in the elliptical case
we are going to use all the possible
value all the possible lands so we are
going to have a larger graph and what is
going to happen is that I so Jenny are
no longer going to commute with each
other it's going to be a little bit
harder but you still can give transport
of stuff transport of of a basis of the
kernel basically for each for each of
these small degree I so Jenny's so that
you can you can forward stuff of course
if you do that you need to choose some
values of alpha are going to belong to
Alice some values are going to belong to
Bob but it's exactly like saying that
alice is going to use I so Jenny of
degree 2 or Bob is going to use a
usually I so Jenny of degree 3
you need to split the small Prime's into
okay and so this is a story you can
really adapt to think everything seems
to work on this is really great
until you realize the following so you
have a pass between sy and Phi which is
a composition of of quite a lot of of
isogen is of degree one so what happens
is that this gives an ID agree I so
journey between fiims and site okay now
if we want to break the skin the only
thing we need to do is to find this big
degree isogen if we can do that
basically we have solved the elementary
problems that is behind the scene and
what we are going to do here is we are
going to use the fact that even if this
as kind of I'd agree there is a compact
representation so if you have done these
steps the degree is D but it's only
going to be defined by D constant from
the finite field okay and and in fact
it's easier to attack the non
commutative case because in the non
commutative cares we have given
images of points by this so if you just
look at the images of point by Z's you
know that this yota evaluated at the
fixed point is giving the given points
that you have at the end and each such
assertion is a linear equation and the
coefficient and you have enough equation
just to have a linear system that you
can solve so if you want to do is a side
eh with with drinfeld module it's
immediately broken by linear algebra and
what happen if you want to do the
commutative case it turns out as that
this gives an equation kind of a
polynomial system of equation which is
much harder to solve lands and doing
linear algebra but they are still
recursive way to solve it efficiently so
even the commutative case is also broken
which is a pity because Y adaptation was
really going nicely and everything was
was perfectly in line with what we
wanted but it turns out that it doesn't
work before that there was a space hash
function based on misogyny so we don't
actually need to have polies to pass on
you just need to have like it as half of
this visual
would that still be secure in your case
or is this one no you can't find pass
you give me two points in the graph I
can't find out pass between the two as
long as the length of the of course is
the length of the pass is is several
thousand kilometers and I will not be
able to find it but yeah
yeah do these good not easier but do
these things mean anything like why do
people study transferred murders in the
first place it seems like a pretty
random thing right do you know oh well I
think it's first started with we study
by of calyx module and but but basically
what people say number theory if well
it's kind of difficult but this is that
that this terrific module are kind of
function field analog of elliptic curve
they are really even even this so it's
much much harder but even this picture
exists with with rainfall modules you
have lettuces but instead of being in
the complex there are in a much more
complicated things which is you need to
take the Attic and then you need to take
the algebraic closure and then you need
to take the completion and then it's
fine but but but you have something and
the problem here is that you can have
lettuces of dimension more than two and
they are still relevant which is why you
have rainfall module of rank 3 4 5 etc
so it's a very it's a very rich picture
but but kind of tour rich maybe for for
crypto purpose because you have too many
tools and I don't know so just the
question is sort of walked on the side
if someone has to me for elliptic curve
analog for function fields I might have
suggested an elliptic curve over a
function field but that somehow must be
simplistic is there a connection to
develop modules there's something wrong
with just taking you cubic equation and
virus transform over a function field so
that you can also do but but for some ok
I don't know exactly
why so it gives you there's a much
richer structure if you use all the
drinfeld module if you're studying the
arithmetical function fields twin field
modules you can think of as not just per
lift occurs Matchett analogues of
elliptic curves but analogues of CM
elliptic curves because you have these
extra endomorphism rays but in fact you
can you can by taking higher and higher
rank in film on google you get many more
sort of rays acting on them of this form
so it's another tool for studying in
particular it seems to be the richer
objects that that people in numbers ure
prefer to use rather than just yeah but
unfortunately for crypto it doesn't
doesn't turn out well
[Applause]